PROPOSED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BY NOON TOMORROW.
>> THIS IS THE NEWS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN WAITING FOR.
LET'S GO TO KAITLYN POLANCE.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW?
>> Reporter: IT'S JUDICIAL
EXPEDIENCY HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE BY NOON
TOMORROW A VERSION OF THAT
AFFIDAVIT, THE NARRATIVE THAT
BACKED UP THE SEARCH WARRANT OF
MAR-A-LAGO, EVERYTHING THAT
WOULD EXPLAIN THE DETAILS OF THE
INVESTIGATION THAT REQUIRED FBI
TO GO IN AND SEIZE ALL OF THOSE
BOXES OF DOCUMENTS FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S HOME.
THE JUDGE'S ORDER SAYS THAT NOON
TOMORROW IS THE DEADLINE FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO FILE THIS.
TODAY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAD
THEIR OWN DEADLINE WHERE THEY
WERE PROPOSING WHAT THEY WANTED
TO BLACK OUT IN THIS AFFIDAVIT
TO PROTECT THEIR ONGOING
INVESTIGATION, AND ESSENTIALLY
THE JUDGE ACCEPTED THAT.
HE ACCEPTED ALL OF THEIR
REASONINGS, AND HE EVEN OUTLINED
WHAT THOSE REASONINGS WERE,
SPECIFICALLY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WANTS TO PROTECT
WITNESSES, LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS, UNCHARGED PARTIES, SO
PEOPLE WHO COULD BE UNDER
INVESTIGATION, COULD FACE
CHARGES IN THE FUTURE.
ALSO THE STRATEGY, DIRECTION,
SCOPE, SOURCES, METHODS, AND
FINALLY GRAND JURY INFORMATION.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WANTS TO
PROTECT AS THEY HAVE THIS
ONGOING CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
INTO THE HANDLING OF FEDERAL
RECORDS INTO THE HANDLING OF
POTENTIAL NATIONAL DEFENSE
INFORMATION, BUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT AND VERY QUICK FINDING
FROM THE JUDGE TO RELEASE A
VERSION OF THIS AFAFFIDAVIT.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE TOMORROW HOW
BLACKED OUT IT ACTUALLY IS.
>> KATELYN.
WE HAVE SEEN THE REASONS FOR ITS
REDACTIONS, BUT THE JUDGE WENT
ON TO SAY THEY ARE NARROWLY
TAILORED AND THEY DIDN'T GO
OVERBOARD WITH BLACKING OUT TOO
MUCH.
>> Reporter: I'M GLAD YOU POINT
THAT OUT BECAUSE NARROWLY
TAILORED.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DID HAVE
TO SHOW -- THIS IS WHY WE WENT
THROUGH THIS WHOLE PROCESS.
THE GOVERNMENT HAD TO SHOW TO
THE JUDGE THERE WERE SPECIFIC
THINGS AND THE REASONS WHY THOSE
SPECIFIC THINGS SHOULD STAY
UNDER SEAL AS THIS INVESTIGATION
CONTINUES.
OF COURSE, THAT MEANS THERE MAY
NOT BE FULL PAGES BLACKED OUT.
WE COULD SEE LITTLE PIECES OF
THIS AFFIDAVIT, BUT IT IS
ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THAT WE DON'T
LEARN A LOT MORE THAN WE'VE
ALREADY LEARNED ALREADY IN THIS.
IT WILL COME DOWN TO WHAT WE SEE
TOMORROW.
>> BASICALLY JUST TO REITERATE,
THE JUDGE FOUND THE DOJ MADE A
COMPELLING CASE TO BE ABLE TO
BLACK OUT THE IDENTITIES OF
WITNESSES, LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS, UNCHARGED PARTIES AS
WELL AS THE SOURCES AND METHODS
AND THE SCOPE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
SO ALL OF THAT WE CAN EXPECT TO
BE REDACTED.
>> Reporter: YES.
WE DEFINITELY CAN EXPECT ALL OF
THAT TO BE REDACTED AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR IN COURT THROUGHOUT THESE
PROCEEDINGS WHERE THERE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW MUCH
CAN BE TRANSPARENT HERE.
THE ARGUMENT FOR TRANSPARENCY
HAS BEEN THAT THIS IS A HISTORIC
SEARCH.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED, AND THERE
REALLY IS A PUBLIC INTEREST TO
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WE CAN KNOW AT
THIS POINT IN THE INVESTIGATION,
BUT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN SO CLEAR IN SAYING THEY
WANT TO PROTECT A LOT OF THINGS,
SOURCES AND METHODS, AND SOURCES
IS A HUGE PART OF THIS.
THAT IS WITNESSES, PEOPLE THAT
THEY HAVE SPOKEN TO WHO
POTENTIALLY MAY BE IDENTIFIABLE
BASED ON WHAT THEY TOLD
INVESTIGATORS TO ALLOW FOR THIS
SEARCH TO HAPPEN.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT THOSE
WITNESSES.
THEY ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY PROTECT PEOPLE WHO THEY MAY
NEED INFORMATION FROM IN THE
FUTURE IF THEY WERE TO CHARGE A
CASE, IF THEY HAVE MORE TO
INVESTIGATE, AND SO PROTECTION
OF WITNESSES, THE OTHER REASON
WHY THAT'S SO IMPORTANT IN THIS,
IS BECAUSE THIS IS AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION AS WELL AS AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE HANDLING
OF FEDERAL RECORDS, AND SO
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
PROTECTED IF THEY ARE SOMEHOW
BECOMING PART OF YOUR
INVESTIGATION.
>> CERTAINLY, KATELYN, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
FILING TO UNSEAL THE SEARCH
WARRANT AND THE PROPERTY
RECEIVED, WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
THE DOJ ON CAMERA FROM THIS.
SHOULD WE EXPECT THERE WILL BE
MORE THAN THIS FILING, THAT
THERE WILL BE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL COMING BACK TO SAY
ANYTHING?
>> Reporter: I GUESS WE COULD
NEVER -- WE COULD NEVER REALLY
KNOW UNTIL THERE WOULD BE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ITSELF, BUT IN THE
WAY THAT THIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WORKS, WHAT THEY HAVE SAID SO
FAR ABOUT THIS IS THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO SPEAK THROUGH COURT
FILINGS.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND HAS
SAID THAT HIMSELF WHEN HE MADE
THAT PUBLIC STATEMENT BEFORE,
AND THAT WOULD BE THE VERY
LIKELY WAY FORWARD WITH THIS.
WE DO HAVE A COURT FILING.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT KNOWS WE
WILL BE WATCHING AND THEY WILL
NOWHERE TO PUT THE COURT FILING
AND IT IS EVEN SINCE JANUARY
6th, THE MOST HIGH PROFILE
CASES, THE SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY
CHARGES, WE NEVER EVEN SAW THE
TOP ATTORNEY GENER